arguably the most natural and powerful
form of learning is through experience
or more precisely through reflection on
doing also called experiential learning
it's what prima ballerinas do after
their performance at the National Opera
but it also happens to boys that as sad
because their father got angry when they
played football in the living room by
the age of one we all had our own
painful encounter with experiential
learning when we tried to walk failed
fell and cried like well a baby and even
though this was an unpleasant and
discouraging exercise that lasted for
months in the end we all made it how is
that possible as soon as we fell and the
first shock was over our brain
unconsciously began to make sense out of
all the information available to
identify how this embarrassment occurred
it remembers that when we pushed
ourselves up everything was fine our
feet on the floor our arms in position
and our head and shoulders upright ready
to go when our upper leg muscles pulled
our left foot 12.3% to the front at an
angle of 23 degrees our arms didn't
complement the movement and the
ventricles in the inner ear responsible
for static balance got confused for a
second one at the same moment the cat
ran by our eyes sent an alarming signal
to the hippocampus and we completely
lost it ouch
unconsciously this is how our brain
analyzes the relationship of events
within our body or in the environment it
happens all the time as we learn to walk
talk kiss function in a fancy office or
dance the salsa once we understand the
connections between what went wrong we
know what we need to change when we try
the next time experiential learning can
also be used explicitly to learn a new
skill or to become better at what we
already love doing here is how it works
first get yourself into a situation to
experience after reflect on what
happened then try to understand the
relationships to form an abstract
concept if I do a I get B last decide
what to do differently next time then do
it again
for example if you want to learn how to
ride a bicycle the following might
happen you get onto the bike and start
kicking the pedals as you were afraid of
speed you ride too slowly and you fall
to the side afterward you remember that
you fell at the exact moment when your
speed was the slowest then you form the
abstract and slightly dangerous idea
speed equals stability next time you
decide you'll speed up let's try that
again this time you write fast in fact
so fast that you crashed straight into
the next fruit store your head hurts and
you realize that speeding like that is
really dangerous you create the next
abstract thought speed is danger and
danger needs protection you then decide
to wear a helmet next time experiential
learning is also believed to be
responsible for the fact that musicians
generally fare better at most tests
regardless of what they measure people
that practice an instrument not only
engage their brain in motor visual and
auditory areas but they also learn by
reflecting on what they're doing with a
fast feedback loop a wrong tone on the
violin sounds too terrible to remain
unnoticed
while playing they therefore not only
learn to make music but also that
progress in general comes through
practice reflection understanding and
repetition you can use it with your
friends or colleagues when working on a
project Silicon Valley startups do it
when they tell their developers to get
out of the building after the
interaction with real potential
customers the Tim gets together analyzes
the feedback and decides what to do next
if you are all by yourself learning
something where feedback doesn't come
fast and painfully get going and look
for someone who can give you a second
opinion along the way the students that
can be a friend or the teacher for
entrepreneurs that's the mentor and for
journalists a blog where readers can
comment tell us what do you think is
learning through reflecting on doing
only good when acquiring new hands-on
skills or is it also suitable to study
science math the humanities or abstract
art
you